so today I want to talk about how to
look younger instantly okay this is what
you do very very important start to find
some new friends that are a lot older
than you and just start hanging out with
them and you're going to look a lot
younger but in all seriousness there's
really two viewpoints to look at when
trying to you know look youthful uh the
outside in approach versus the Inside
Out approach so many people are focused
on trying to look younger from the
outside in they're using all sorts of
facial creams and different things are
putting your face to like anti- wrinkle
things and creams and lotions and all
sorts of things not to mention surgery
and those things as well but what about
from the inside out what are some things
you can do to change your youthful
appearance from the inside well let's
start right at the most important thing
and that would be something called age
advanced glycation end products that is
a combination of a sugar and A protein
that is bonded and stuck together these
get stuck in the body and they
accumulate and they make you look older
and they create all sorts of chronic
inflammation in chronic disease so if
you were to take um I don't know
barbecued ribs for example you have
sugar sauce on these ribs and they're
heated so heat tends to cause this
chemical reaction to occur and so
there's a lot of different meals that we
cook like meatloaf for example and it
can even be proteins in junk food right
that's just process it's highly heated
but it can also be the amount of sugar
that you're eating that goes into your
own bloodstream and you have heat inside
your body and it starts to interact with
your own proteins okay you have
something in your blood cells called
hemoglobin there's this thing called
A1C what is that that is a measurement
of how much
glycated protein that you have and it
gives you a number so you can kind of
look at on a scale from good to bad and
you can kind of from that determine your
blood sugars over a period of three
months these ages are behind a lot of
problems with just looking old okay but
you also have something else that's
related a e what is that that stands for
advanced lip oxidation and products okay
that is where you have fat that gets
bound to glucose or sugar so ages are
are sugar and protein that gets stuck Al
are sugar and fat that gets stuck same
thing it creates chronic inflammation
disease and it accumulates and it makes
you look older because think about it
you have various um proteins in your
body you have a lot of different
proteins I mean you have proteins in
your tendons your ligaments you have
protein in your blood but you also have
fat membranes too and then your nervous
system and your endocrine system your
brain and even every cell in your body
has a cell membrane made out of fat
let's say you ate some ice cream right
fat with sugar heated deadly for this
this process of binding this sugar with
this fat you have also uh french fries
right because you have high Heats with a
starch which is a carb which you can
turn into sugar really fast and then the
fat the oil that they cook with then you
have the cereals and the chips the
donuts etc etc now when we talk about um
this Al the one that affects the lipids
um if we look at just saturated fats and
unsaturated fats like seed oils the seed
oils are much worse than the saturated
fats because they're more of an unstable
fat and so if you want to look young you
better avoid those unsaturated fats
because they're going to make you look
old really quick and when I use the word
oxidation I'm talking about the concept
of like certain parts of your body just
like rusting out creating what's called
free radical damage which is another
thing that's a little confusing I think
the best way to understand that is think
about uh if you had a plate that's
spinning on your finger right now around
a circle and it had different weights on
it and if you took one of the weights
off it would be out of balance right and
it would no longer balance because it's
not paired anymore it starts to becoming
very radical and it starts to damage
things too much oxidation and not enough
protection like antioxidants you have
this thing called oxidative stress and
the reason I'm bringing this up is
because this relates directly to your
aging if you could just balance this
thing out back and bring up your
antioxidant levels you can counter all
the oxidation in the free radical damage
to a major level now as you know other
things also oxidize you as well smoking
drinking pollution taking drugs
you know things like that but what's
interesting about this you always hear
someone say well I know of my
grandfather he smoked like a fiend and
he died at 100 years old how do you
explain that well if you take a look at
certain countries where people live a
long time like Sardinia for example
these people that live in the mountains
live a lot longer than people that live
at the sea level okay and uh there's an
interesting uh article on this talking
about men because the men that lived in
the Mountaintop in Sardinia smoke like a
fiend so wait a second I thought smoking
was bad for you how could this possibly
be they should be dead by the time
they're 60 or 70 how are they living
past a hundred years old well yes they
do smoke but they're also consuming a
lot of antioxidants and some of the
antioxidants they're eating are actually
in the cheese that they eat because
they're goats and their sheep consume
grass in the higher altitudes which have
much much higher antioxidant levels and
those transfer into the milk which goes
into the cheese which goes into these
people that smoke not to mention all the
other antioxidants that they eat and
also the lifestyle they're probably not
doing a lot of ultr processed junk Foods
so you really need to look at the whole
picture okay if you're consuming junk
Foods yet at the same time you're doing
other things that are countering that uh
then that could explain why you might be
surviving a lot longer I live in a
certain area where there's a lot of
people who eat junk food but even though
they seem to be eating a lot of junk
food a lot of them are farmers and
they're outside and they're working
until dark right you have all this
physical activity that is so protective
against everything it's probably
countering all the bad effects from the
chewing tobacco and the smoking and all
the junk food if you have enough
antioxidants to the oxidation then
you're going to be in better shape how
can we build up our antioxidant levels
well we can eat animals that had eaten
grass or even a diversified uh group of
plants versus animals have just lived on
grains or we in a feed lot right they're
not going to have near the
phytonutrients and those phytonutrients
are more protective against things in
fact I'm my farm I sent my beef into the
study and the researcher contacted me
after six months and says what are you
doing I says what do you mean he says
let me send you the report so I'll put
the page up right now but you can see in
this report the level of antioxidants
compared to other Farms right so my
cattle not only get a lot of exercise
because there's nothing flat there's
just mountains up and down and there's
not even a lot of grass there's just a
lot of different weeds and different
plants and different herbs which
obviously is contributed to these
phytonutrients and so when you go to
like Europe uh France and Italy we have
some cheese where these goats and sheep
that have lived on different types of
grasses and higher altitudes I think
they're more protective but another
Viewpoint could be this these
antinutrients can create an epigenetic
effect just like exercise does right on
our bodies when you exercise you
actually damage your body that then
causes an adaptation and you become
stronger the same thing with cold
therapy or heat therapy or fasting well
what about some of these uh plant-based
chemicals right it could be doing the
same thing we don't know yet but with
time I think we'll figure this out if we
want to build up our own antioxidants
and I'm talking about endogenous that
means from within our body makes these
antioxidants there's various ways we can
do that okay we can do that by consuming
antioxidants like if you were to consume
food like cruciferous vegetables the
phytonutrients in those cruciferous
vegetables like sulfurane for broccoli
Sprouts or radishes will actually not
only give us some antioxidants it will
trigger our genes are enzymes from those
genes to make antioxidants another way
you can increase your own endogenous
antioxidants is through
fasting exercise and sleeping and the
more antioxidants you have the better
you're also able to detoxify as well
because one thing about our skin our
youthfulness we want a good
detoxification system we don't want to
build up toxic waste and so we need a
very healthy liver if you ever take a
look at someone who has a bad liver okay
their skin is always bad it doesn't look
healthy now all of those things also
trigger something else it's called
autophagy Now what is autophagy
autophagy is a a condition where your
body starts to
recycle damage cells and damage things
within cells to repurpose them for new
cells and theophagy can also help you
look younger as well now if we look on
the posing scale of that frequent eating
eating a lot of sugar eating a lot of
grains eating a lot of ultra processed
foods will stop autophagy now what do I
mean by alra processed foods well if we
just take a look at the definition of
the word processed what does that mean
it means to change something to alter
something to modify something as in
modified food starch right and then if
we add this other word before it called
Ultra we're talking about extreme change
okay and making it so dead those are the
foods that are on the bottom level that
aren't really even Foods they're
chemicals
and the more of those foods you eat the
older you're going to look the more
unhealthier you're going to look those
things are designed to sit on the shelf
for a long time and if you think about
it even the bugs won't eat them the
other thing about creating a useful
appearance is to make sure that your
your liver is working especially with
this thing called bile bile is made by
your liver and it helps you extract fat
cable nutrients from the food that you
eat so what depletes bile
going on a lowfat diet this is why if
you're on a low-fat diet your skin your
hair dries out it doesn't look as
healthy there's a diet out there it's
called Ideal Protein and they use soy
protein isets which is like this
modified soybean right and like a powder
and they use other ingredients that are
really really cheap so it's kind of like
a lowfat version of Keto because it's
low carb I have noticed in practice that
when people do this diet they lose
weight but they start to look kind of
older they look dried out also if we
look at the type of fat that you should
be eating the saturated fats are very
stable the unsaturated fats are very
unstable and this is why when you buy
these oil seed oils at the store and
they're sitting out what's keeping them
from going rancid they're already rancid
so when you consume them in salad
dressings mayonnaise basically it's in
most of the foods at the grocery store
so you really have to start reading the
labels and if it says soy oil canola or
cotton seed oil or safflower oil or
sunflower seed oil I would avoid those
and on your salad I would put real
extraversion olive oil maybe some
vinegarette now I do want to bring up
this point on cholesterol cholesterol
has a purpose and the purpose of
cholesterol is to help make hormones
also um the cholesterol is needed to
make cell membranes so when someone is
either on a Statin drug which blocks
cholesterol or they're on a low
saturated fat diet because they been
told they have to replace their
saturated fats with the unsaturated fats
which is probably the biggest mistake in
history because it's created more
problems especially obesity than
anything else if you take a look at the
graph of obesity over time sugar
actually has gone down but the only
thing that hasn't gone down is the seed
oils it keeps going higher and higher
and higher and so another good fat is
the omega-3 fats from fish oils could be
sardines salmon cod liver oil is a
really good one that I like because it
not only has the omega-3 it has the
vitamin D and the vitamin A vitamin A is
really really important vitamin A um
supports all of your skin both
externally and also inside your body one
of the best sources of vitamin A is from
egg yolk now you can also get an omega-3
or at least a precursor it's called ala
from walnuts okay but I would recommend
getting the sprouted walnuts or just buy
walnuts soak them in water overnight
then dry them out in the oven for a
little bit and then consume them that
way you don't have any of the um the
things that can create digestive issues
and then you get um the sun okay the sun
can make you look older especially if
you allow the skin to burn if you are in
the Sun and you just get a slight tan um
and you don't overdose it it's going to
be okay and you're not going to actually
age the skin what happens when you're
out in the sun as well and we need sun
is that we also get uh over 50% of the
rays are
infrared infrared is very very
therapeutic to your skin infrared can
penetrate like two inches inside the
body and it goes in the body and it can
help increase melatonin and it's not
just for sleep it's also a very powerful
antioxidant so when you're exposing your
your skin to Sun okay you don't overdo
it it's a healthy thing but some people
can overdo it I know as a teenager I I
overdid it you know I let myself get
burned so many times well that's not
healthy you know that can really age
your skin anyway right now you know the
secret to looking youthful and younger
so now your next step is to go out and
apply what I just said if you have not
seen my video on exactly what you should
be eating I put that up right here check
it
out